OH MY GOD IT'S THANOS. Tha-
woah. dayum.
Thanos I didn't realize you were so thicc
DAMN BOI HE THICC
hahaha oh jesus
how's it going bros
my name is peeeewwwdiepieee
and BROFIST *wow the nostalgia*
*brofist brofist brofist*
ha ha ha I love that sound
alright yes I'm still playing this game
brofist
I've added mods to the game which makes it even crazier than it used to be, and
it's honestly the best ever so...
lets frickin j u m p into it
uh-uuuhh
it's a fresh day.. for some fresh knees (yes ofc why not) *moan*
boop boop boop boop boop
lets pick the hardest difficulty (yah that'll go great im sure)
and lets frickin do this
I'm ready like I've never been ready before
OH MY GAAAAAAWD
please
I don't wanna hit a woman
AGHHH
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU
ugh... ughhh...ugh-HUH
that's for your kne-hee-hee-hees..
HAHHH
how DARE you
AH
c'mere, c'mere
your knees up BI- (Christian channel)
eagh
*incoherent grunting*
AWWHHH
huh BYE
*final grunt
*dramatic flute music
alright lets try that again
*laugh
OH MY GOD
OH MY GOD IT'S THANOS
THAN- woahhh
DAMN
Thanos I didn't realize you were so thicc
Oh my gawd
oh these are some precious knees (wtf)
oh... oh... oh... oh... ah...
ohhh (tf)
oh huh huh huh  huh huh
BYEEE
aw yeah heah
that's how we frickin do it in Sweden bros
alright lets get some real action
*more dramatic flute music
hooh
hoo
ah sorry
Oh
uh sorry
YOUR KNEES ARE MINE
MINE
*Unintelligible noises*
Yeah
*Heavy breathing and sniffing*
Swedish jump attack!!!!1!!!1!2
HAAAAAAAAAAAAA
BEH
AAAAAAAH
*grunt*
BUH
Stay Down
Are you still alive?
Do you regret what you did?
*neck snap*
Too late
Holololololololololololololololololol
Bye
Ha ha ha ha
Who wants some?
Jesus Christ
So ridiculous
Hugh
Oh, god dammit
That didn't do anything
Excuse me
One second ma'am
*Hold music*
Don't come near me
I'll never hit a whamen
Please
Please, vox is lit...
oh
Oh, you did it
that was you
Get her knees
oohhhh
Ha ha ha ha ha
That is not as cool as I wanted it to be
Are you still alive?
Oh my god you are still alive
Excuse me, we do not have to fight anymore
Oh look, a spear
Now lets put it, where it belongs
k n e e s
I got one knees
I got two knees
I was born in the knees
I was bleed by the...
I was bred by the knees
Do you speak knee-jitsu
*woman grunts*
*woman yelps*
*woman yelps some more*
*woman grunts once again*
Nothing to see here YouTube
Nothing to see here
Alright, lets change map
Wow what an adventure
But, theres more places to go
And more knees to be found
Lets go to the market
And acquire knees legally
Whats on the menu?
Oh, what's crazy endless?
Ok, lets do that
Oh my got it's so tiny
That is so cute
It just died right away
Oh, sorry
Excuse me, can I have that back please
Bitch
You're shooting arrows at me
Really? please
Please
Don't hurt me
Don't hurt
Aaaaaaaaaarrrrrrgh
*Panting*
I'm coming...
Aaaaaaaarrrrrrrrrgh
Damn
*Panting*
*grunting*
You will never walk
*heavy breathing*
*grunting*
agrh
Ha, you hit a whaman
How could you?
Oopsie!
oopsie
What are you gonna do, huh? What are you gonna do, hu-
Ah, terrible
sneak attack
Ah he's got knee pads
YYEAAHHH
arhh
uogh
oh hA HA HA HA HA
*laughing*
Where did she go?
Oh there she is.
yachk yakh
mm
nyACH
*grunting*
Oh my god.
*more grunting*
knee
*grunting*
ah she knows how to block
SHAME ON YOU!
SHAME ON YOU
Gimme back my knee dagger!
Aw what are gonna do?
What are you gonna do hUh?
Useless! Pathetic!
AAAAAAAHHHH!
AAAAH
AH
EHG
YOU'RE CRAZY! YOU COULD HURT ME!
*pant*
Just wait until I get ya!
Just wait until I get those knees
AH *incomprehensible suffering*
AH
NYEH
HUP
AHH WHGHA FEHHH
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
*heavy breathing*
DEH
UEGH
UGEH
GOD
DAMMIT
*grunting*
*dramatic flute music*
uegh
eHG
haa
aahhh
aaahhh
ahhHH What have I d-
Please, I'm having a moment.
I'm having a real bad day.
Please!
Please I beg you!
I have nothing to live for. I got nothing and no one. (TikTok)
That's what you thought, b!tch.
(evil laughter)
I don't care if (???)
I'll hit any child -I mean.. person.
Please don't hurt me!
Please don't -oh my god you fell for that?
You're gonna pay.
you're gonna!
pay!
Your knees are USELESS!
Have a bucket.
Ha ha ha. Ningen.. BAKARO
KNEE!
Oops!
I fight you all with my bucket!
Anyone else want bucket?
Hwuh!
hwuh
Tell me, child.
Where is your knee?
*high-pitched voice* I don't know what you're talking a-
WHERE ARE THEY?
I know you have them!
Where are they hidden?
*high-pitched* I swear I don't have any
DAHH! AAH DON'T LIE TO ME!
*high-pitched* I don't have the knees I swear. I have a fa-
*aggressively grunting*
*panting*
I'm gonna ask you one last time.
Where are your knees?
*high-pitched* Please, don't do thi-
GAAH *snaps neck*
AAHH
Okay I think it's time to stop. *laughing* Jesu-
Smash like!
YOUR KNEES ARE MINE!
I was born in the knees
OH HE'S GOT KNEE PADS!
Give me back my knee dagger!
Just wait until I get those knees!
Your knees are USELESS!
Where are your knees?
*high-pitched* I don't have the knees, I swear
*high-pitched* Pleaase, don't touch my knee
DON'T TALK TO ME ABOUT KNEES!
*high-pitched* My chime(?) is in my knee
*groan* Oh I don't think so, Dr. phil
Cuz I
Are you gonna keep copystriking my videos?
Dr. Phil?
Huh?
Ah shi- Ah godammit uh
You want pyramids?
We got 'em!
Oh you're into castles huh?
WE GOT YOU COVERED BABY!
You want some PETS?
EASY!
WE! GOT IT! ALL!
This game is STILL relevant goddammit!